from riyadh and saudi arabia's political
and military elite
came a proposal they want to end the war
in yemen and they had some carrots for
the houthis
we will do all we can to put the
necessary pressure
on the houthis to accept and to come
to the negotiating table and to lay down
arms because we believe that
a stop to the fighting and a focus on a
political solution
is the only way forward this is herded
port
held by the houthis but under blockade
by the saudi coalition
meaning most fuel and food imports are
not getting through
this is sana international airport held
by the houthis
but has not seen regular commercial
flights since 2015.
the saudi government is proposing to
ease the blockade on her data port
and allow some flights to resume at sana
airport
add to that new political negotiations
and a nationwide un-supervised ceasefire
the iran-backed houthis quickly rejected
the proposal
stating the opening of ports and
airports is a humanitarian right
and not a bargaining chip
what is demanded is first to lift the
blockade and allow the entry of oil
derivatives
and that is when we will begin to talk
about a ceasefire we are ready for that
we have offered several initiatives to
stop the war aggression
and sending drones and ballistic
missiles to saudi arabia
these are our demands u.s president joe
biden has rescinded support for saudi
arabia in yemen
and reversed a decision to label the
houthis as terrorists
he appointed timothy leader king as a
special envoy to yemen who renewed talks
with stakeholders
the u.s proposed a ceasefire last week
which the houthis rejected
saying riyadh must first lift its sea
and air blockade
american will to end the conflict is
high and yet
it seems the prospect of peace may be
fueling the war
we have seen uh serious escalations
uh on the huda side and on saudi
arabia's side so it
tells us that uh it seems that both
parties are aware that they're coming to
uh there might be coming to an end uh
soon and they're trying to uh have the
upper hand on the ground in order to
improve their negotiation position
now six years into the war neither side
wants to lose
and yet as they fight to win yemenis are
dying every day
succumbing to war to disease to famine
charlotte ballas al jazeera